[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight when you listen to Nancy
Pelosi tell it impeaching the president
is really the last thing she ever wanted
to do in fact she hadn't even considered
it really until the day that the news of
Trump's norming phone call with the
president of Ukraine emerged into public
view it was at that point that
impeachment became entirely inevitable
inevitable as a patriotic American and a
person of deep and sincere and
passionate religious faith Nancy Pelosi
really had no choice at that point the
die was cast she had to remove the
president from office immediately
so that's Nancy Pelosi story we don't
read minds on the show so we can't
really tell you if it's true or not what
we can say with absolute certainty
provable certainty is that permanent
Washington has been thinking about
impeaching Donald Trump for an awfully
long time in fact before he was even
elected president if you could imagine
that they were thinking about impeaching
him
consider the following clip it's from a
woman called Evelyn Farkas Farkas was an
Obama appointee at the Defense
Department she helped run the last
administration's believe it or not
Ukraine policy she was also an
enthusiastic booster of the Hillary
Clinton for president campaign in 2016
so two weeks before the last election
Farkas appeared at a panel discussion
which thankfully for us was videotaped
someone asked Farkas who she thought
would win the election and here's what
she said we do have a strong system of
checks and balances and actually if
Donald Trump were elected I believe he'd
be impeached pretty quickly or somebody
else would have to take over government
and I'm not even joking if Trump were
ever to get elected and of course that's
likely not to happen she said he would
be impeached now to be completely clear
we are not alleging that Evelyn Farkas
was part of a conspiracy conspiracy
suggest secrecy and what Farkas and the
rest of the national security state did
was not secret it was never hidden they
all but bragged about it they hated
Donald Trump from day one now yes Donald
Trump is vulgar but that had nothing to
do with why they hated him they
disagreed with Trump profoundly and by
the way disagree with most American
voters on the issues particularly on the
question of
Russia but also in the question of
Middle East Journal Wars but more than
anything and this is the key they
couldn't control what Donald Trump said
or did
nobody can and that was the unforgivable
crime so from day one they planned to
take him out this Ukraine nonsense is
just the latest pretext for doing it
there have been a lot of them Russia
stormy Daniels fill-in-the-blanks it's
like Mad Libs
a story in The New York Times this
morning reveals every bit as much that
this is just yet another pretext it
turns out that house Intel Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff knew about the
whistleblower complaint before it was
even filed in fact he orchestrated the
story in secret long before you were AI
or anyone else in the country heard
about it the so-called whistleblower
contacted shifts office which
recommended a lawyer for him or her
shift leader lied about that on
television brazenly openly he claimed
his office had never spoken to the CIA
employee directly she have had to know
admitting that would undermine the story
and hence impeachment himself although
it's night there are credible rumors
that Adam Schiff himself planted today's
bombshell New York Times story he knew
it would come out and he wanted the most
sympathetic possible coverage that's the
line we can't confirm that but either
way the story this morning gravely
damages the credibility of the claims
Schiff and others are making not that
anyone in Washington really cares
they've been waiting for this moment for
three years no matter what the story was